at this point we are nine marks in um i
just want to pause for a second and let
you post in the chat
did that make sense to you were you able
to follow it um or are there any
particular lines that it would be
valuable for me to go back to just to
explain them a little more just because
there's a smaller number of us in the
room i wonder if anyone wants to say no
that's okay or can you go back to this
line or that line what do you guys think
is anyone still conscious
um have you been knocked out by all of
the
algebra
you you're happy susie okay wonderful
all right um yeah i hope you're with us
as well let's do the final part here we
go
part four
prove that
two to the power of n n factorial all
squared is less than or equal to and
then you've got all that stuff okay
now uh
it's a bit hard to see um but this
result here part four i wonder if it
looks familiar to you
part 4
doesn't connect so much to part 3 and
this jn thing right because do you
remember to do part 3 we kind of got rid
of
we got rid of this 2 to the 2n term here
right we're going through all of that
new uh recurrence relation we can't set
out the 2n it was gone but now have a
look at part 4. this 2 to the n
squared that's 2 to the 2n if you just
have a look at
let me just make that obvious 2 to the n
squared those things clearly combine
into 2 to the 2n
uh the 2 to the 2 ends back right so
you're like hold up um i just spent all
this effort getting rid of it why is it
gone okay and the answer is this is not
made obvious at all i really had to
think about this quite hard for myself
that's because part four
doesn't actually need part three it
actually goes back to both part three
and part four independently
flow out of part one and two so if you
want like a diagrammatical
representation of this right there's
part one uh that flows into part two
and then uh those two together
separately
solve part three and
part four not that that's obvious at all
just by looking at the question but
that's just so that you can see why i'm
now subsequently not really going to
think about part three
so again you can see there's this
obvious connection here to um part two
right you've got the 2 to the 2n there
at the top you've also got the n
factorial squared up the top there and
then look at this 2n plus 1 factorial
it's just the denominator right so this
almost looks like exactly what we got
from part two but with an equal
inequality in there right so what this
is saying is essentially um if you
divide through by both sides by 2n plus
1 factorial you're going to get 2 n
n factorial
squared i should have said 2 to the n i
can divide through by 2n plus 1
factorial because that's a positive
number um think about where n is defined
and factorials how they're defined so
dividing through by positive number
preserves the direction of the
inequality so it's going to be still
less than or equal to and you just get
left with one on the right hand side so
we're trying to prove something about i
n and the fact that it's less than or
equal to one
how do we do that okay
now gonna pull a trick here that um is
not obvious at all um i know
um but if you think about what's being
asked of you right
weirdly let me just go back a little bit
weirdly
even though it looks so bizarre
this is actually something which we know
which we need advanced knowledge not
even extension one knowledge to work
with you're like really mr wu really we
only need advanced knowledge that's not
entirely true but it's an advanced
concept right think all the way back to
when integration was first introduced to
you because that's what this thing is
right if this is i n
this is i n
is less than or equal to one what is an
integral we were first introduced to
integrals uh with the idea of finding
out areas under a curve can you remember
that it was a long time ago right
what we're trying to show here is
whatever this integral is and it can
change based on what value of n you take
on if n equals 0 or n equals 1 or n
equals 2 is something you're less than
or equal to 1 right
well i actually already know some
concrete values of i n that prove or not
prove that give examples of how this is
true let's just go back in our working
right
when i was doing part 2
i had to work out like this this whole
product these terms that the product
began with and these terms that the
product ended with right so we worked
out i zero we didn't think about areas
at all but you can see here that this
integral here if we can work out what
that looks like apparently the area
under that curve in this domain is 1.
then when you have a look here
apparently the area under that curve for
i1 the next integral up is 2 3. that's
less than or equal to 1 that seems to
check out and as you go further and
further along i wonder if you can see
you're going to keep getting smaller and
smaller and smaller because each of
these numbers as you multiply up and up
the steps of the recurrence relation can
you see the is always bigger than the
numerator can you see that it's 2n plus
1 as compared to 2n so as you multiply
by each one
we start at 1 we go to 2 thirds the next
one along is just going to be smaller
and smaller and smaller so that gives us
an intuition as to why let me try and
show you a picture and a picture is
actually part of what we're going to
need to prove for this right
at least to do it elegantly
here is sine 2 theta from naught to pi
on 2. now i think about why this is what
sine 2 theta looks like you know regular
sine theta goes and does the half cycle
the up and then down from naught to pi
but sine 2 theta is twice as frequent
right the period is half the length so
that's why instead of going from nor to
pi you go from naught to pi on two so
that's why you get the entire cycle in
this compressed space
now you can see here i've actually got
two graphs on top of each other which
you can't quite see because what i'm
testing out is this sine 2 theta raised
to this power
but i'm testing out the power for n
equals 0. for n equals 0
you've got 2 times 0 plus 1 so it's just
sine 2 theta to the power of 1. that's
sine 2 theta but i want you to look at
what happens as i increase the value of
n
i was a bit sneaky i should be an
integer land but you'll see why actually
it's okay not to be just for this
particular result watch what happens as
i slide out from n equals 0
to n equals 1 because you actually know
what that area is right it's two-thirds
that's what we've worked out from
evaluating the integral let me go from n
equals 0
up to n equals 1.
there it is
do you see what just happened let me
actually just go back for a second right
there's n equals zero
why is it that you sort of get this
weird compressed shape i'll do it one
more time into n equals
one
there it is right there ah my finger's
too stubby okay think about what the um
the range not the domain think about the
range of the sine function is uh in this
compressed spot it's going from naught
to one not to one
now as you multiply this thing by itself
that's what sine two theta raised to
this power does as you multiply by
yourself because your numbers are from 0
to 1 they're fractions that are smaller
than 1 so as you multiply by those
numbers you get smaller right i mean 0
times 0 is 0 so those are the endpoints
and 1 times 1 is 1 so that's the top
there but everything else gets smaller
and as i make it smaller and smaller and
smaller you can see it just compresses
further and i mean i arbitrarily stopped
at 9 but you can go as far as you'd like
for all values of n this is just going
to get smaller and smaller and smaller
so this is kind of the the dna of my
proof um me showing you this dynamically
obviously you're not going to do this in
um in an exam you're just like i'm going
to pull out desmos okay totally not
allowed but
this is what's happening in my brain as
i'm trying to think through visually
what does all of this algebra and all
this integration mean so i invite you
now with me to consider
the graphs of this is literally how i
would do my working i would consider
the graphs
of
sine two theta
which was that red dotted one that you
saw before
sine two theta
and sine 2 theta raised to this power 2n
plus 1
of 2 theta okay so i apologize it's
going to be very very quick and messy
but
i'm just going to be up here in oh wow
that's horrendous um i'm going to do it
this way make a bit thicker will be
easier
we're just up here in the first quadrant
that's better
and we know we are getting that familiar
just the first hump of sine
sine wow that's too much of a
semi-circle
there we go
it's quick and dirty i'm okay with that
there's sine 2 theta so this is
y equals sine 2 theta
and because i can say let's go off to
the axis here this i'm restricted from
naught to one right naught to one so
that's why as you multiply this thing
gets smaller and smaller right so
therefore um let's put it in green
you're going to get you've got this
shape uh that's terrible i have to move
myself so i can draw it a little more
accurately there we go there's on the
left hand side i'll do the same thing on
the right hand side there you go that is
going to be y equals
sine r to the power 2 and plus 1 of 2
theta so it's a generalization because
obviously the actual curvature of it
changes as the value of n changes but
they're all kind of this this sort of
family of curves okay
now therefore i can say hey hold up um
from this graph right i can say that
this um the i n terms which are the
green ones are always less than or equal
to the i zero term because of the areas
right that area is always constrained
underneath so i can say from the graphs
the and i'll make it um i'll put it in
green for you so you can see that's i n
that's that graph there and it's well
it's an area under the curve that's
always going to be less than or equal to
the area under the curve of the original
one and it's equal to it exactly when n
equals 0 because you get i 0 and i 0 on
both sides right
but hold up
back from part 2 i know what i zero is
it's equal to remember 1. we did that in
working out that long product so
therefore we've got i n is less than or
equal to one at this point you've kind
of done the hard part i just need to do
a bit of algebra to get to the result
that they want um from part two i can
say that this is what i n is equal to n
factorial squared
on 2n plus 1
all factorial
less than or equal to 1 that's from
uh part 2.
that's that's my substitution of um the
i n there and then i'm going to multiply
across i'm going to do that same trick
that i did before in my rough working i
said that's a 2 to the 2n on the
numerator with the n factorial squared
i'm going to multiply through and please
please please when you're dealing with
inequalities it's like a classic thing
that everyone misses they multiply
through by things and if there's some
algebraic nature to it like this is 2n
plus 1 you need to qualify that you can
do this and not muck around with the
direction of the inequality i can say
this since the thing that i multiplied
through by 2n plus 1 factorial it has to
be positive that's why the inequality is
all fine
and then at this point last thing i just
have to factorize the left hand side so
we'll take out the square really so it's
2 oops it does
2 to the n being squared and an n
factorial that's also being squared
that's all equal to or less than or
equal to
the result
on the left-hand side
as required
so um i hope that made sense i hope it
was able to click for you in your mind
not just be able to follow the working
but to think about why the working is
what it is um and yeah as as mrs lees
has pointed out even though uh there
there are weird twists and turns here i
hope you can see the connections to what
you've seen in extension one and in
advance uh it's really
even though i started this off by saying
the technical term of this kind of
question is an absolute nightmare um
some math teachers potentially myself
included would also call this an
absolutely delightful question um
because it helps you to explore all
these different corners of of
mathematics from this one simple idea as
it were which was the integral that we
started with and it kind of opened the
door to all these weird and
sophisticated results